Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today.
Rachel Bitter Cofer, who's an election forecaster
and analyst, host of the podcast The Election
Whisperer, as well as the founder of Strike
Pack.
Rachel, always great having you on.
Thank you.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
And David, I have to update my bio because
I left stroke back in April and do independent
work now.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Well, we will make that change.
We will update that.
So, listen, you don't usually there is this
conventional wisdom when Democrats run on
issues like abortion and gun safety, it doesn't
do anything to get Democrats out to vote.
But it angers Republicans.
It gets Republicans out to vote against Democrats.
And yet, when we look at the polling over
the last two months, it seems as though talking
about Roe v Wade and talking about Republican
inaction on gun safety is actually activating
the Democratic base.
And all of a sudden, the numbers are not looking
as bad for Democrats as they typically would
in the first midterm after winning the White
House.
Is that an accurate assessment?
Or am I missing something?
Speaker 6: No.
I mean, no.
I'm going to say it's not amnesty.
Say there are some things that I would push
back on.
There is a perception.
Right.
And I'm sure the progressive left is used
to hearing this excuse as to why cultural
issues have not been focused on in Democratic
campaigns, this idea of cross mobilization.
Right, if you're trying to mobilize your own
base, but all you do is motivate the other
one, that there is absolutely no data to support
that assertion.
And I have tried to prove it qualitatively
before.
So it's really important for people to understand
that, you know what, the Republican Party
has been fed that kind of messaging for years
and it doesn't necessarily motivate us.
What motivates us is a fear or threat catalyst.
So we look at what happened in Kansas last
night.
I started talking once the memo leaked for
the ro evisceration sort of that if that memo
comes to fruition and they, you know, repeal
Roe and all these abortion laws go into effect,
the GOP is going to be able to ban, you know,
total abortion ban in the places they have
trifecta control.
What we're going to see is, is a potentially
a something so strong and so catastrophic
in the body politic that you could see a momentum
change from the fundamental midterms of midterm
fundamentals that are against the party.
Right.
And so what we saw initially was spontaneous
protest pop up everywhere.
That was a really good data sign, something
similar to what we saw in 2017 and 2018 when
we saw the Trump effect coming.
And then, of course, Kansas is our first election
since then.
It was, of course, heavily focused on it was
the only thing on the ballot.
So it's really important for people to understand
that abortion salience from from ROE is a
product in Kansas, is a product of it being
heavily focused on.
So it's really important people focus on it's
not going to be some residual effect that
they can tap into without trying to harvest
it.
And it's based on negative Partizanship people
are people who are active on our side, especially
when they feel threatened and when Biden got
elected, a lot of people roll back that fear
and now it's back.
Speaker 1: And so when you look at the FiveThirtyEight
Senate forecast, for example, which has kind
of ticked up and up, where now it says Democrats
have a 57% chance of holding the Senate, that
is the result of exactly the factors you just
listed.
Speaker 6: Yes.
These are quantitative metrics.
So I put out I mean, if you follow me regularly
on Twitter and I recommend you do and just
read my thread because it's really where I
do most of my analysis these days because
of time limitations, you'll see that I start
talking about midterm effects.
The midterm in the four year presidential
term always hurts the party because the end
party is the one getting all the bad headlines
right, especially faces and dishonest opposition.
Right.
And so when I talked about the midterm effect,
I said, listen, there's been two interruptions
in the midterm effect.
Both of those were times when the national
conversation got disrupted, and the most recent
was 2002 with Bush, because keep in mind,
he was ceded into the presidency of a very,
very large controversy and was not popular.
No. 911.
Right.
And so that midterm would have been bruising
for Republicans and instead they gained seats.
So I started talking about, you know, look,
if we're going to we can't just bear our heads
in the sand and pretend that fundamentals
don't matter.
So let's try to move the mechanisms that move
the midterm effect and what those are.
That's about national referendum on the Republican
Party.
And we really are starting to see the system,
you know, resonate those changes and data.
Speaker 1: So in 2002, like you say at the
time of the midterms, the president had a
high approval rating as a result of 911.
Right now, Joe Biden has a very low approval
rating.
I went back and looked it looks like you have
to go back to 19, 1946 or 45 when a president
at this point in their first term had this
low an approval rating, it was Truman.
Is the expectation that with Biden at 37%
that that will specifically hurt Democrats
in November or have the have to become disaggregated
to some degree now versus 20 years ago?
Speaker 6: Oh, absolutely disaggregated.
And every time somebody tells me, Oh, I did
the cross time analysis or it was like, this
is 1993 and I'm like, Yeah, I did that because
polarization is not it's not some buzzword.
It's a quantifiable behavioral characteristic
that manifest in behavior across elites, the
mass public, politicians, media system.
And it has caused it has really disrupted
the ability to look back in time and make
comparisons, because let me explain why Biden's
approval rating is so low and also lower than
Donald Trump.
Donald Trump's, when any objective assessment
would definitely tell you which of these two
presidencies were more controversial, turbulent.
And the reason is because hyper partizanship
and polarization is asymmetrical.
It affects the right side of the aisle more,
which is why the Republican Party is having
a flirt with fascism moment here and one of
the ways that it manifests as tribal allegiance.
So when whatever happens with Donald Trump,
no matter how bad the headline was that week,
his approval rating was stagnant, was a flat
line.
That should never happen in a healthy democracy.
Guy And once you started to see in an elastic
presidential approval, you start to realize,
okay, I'm measuring latent partizanship in
the electorate and not actual objectivity.
So what you see with Biden in the why he's
worse than Trump guys you're going to love
this is because progressive Democrats are
willing to tell pollsters that they're dissatisfied
with what the administration's been able to
get done.
So you actually see an 8020 partizan split
on approval for Democrats versus what you
might see in 90, 95, ten for Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: If so, I don't really make economic
predictions.
But just in taking a look at different indicators,
it seems to me that next Tuesday we're going
to get an inflation number for July.
That's significantly lower than that from
June.
There is going to be the ability for Democrats
to accurately talk about the economy is looking
better as we get into November.
With the three months that remain between
now and the midterm elections, is there an
opportunity to get back to talking about the
economy?
Will it will it make a difference?
Is that what Democrats should do if indeed
inflation starts declining and the numbers
look better?
Speaker 6: I mean, here's the thing, and I
talk about this a lot.
There's three issues that are going to dominate
the midterm in terms of the availability of
issues to affect things, which is mostly one
coalition will turn out, but also conversion
pull that ten or 15% of pure independents
who can be affected are going to be affected
by the national atmosphere.
And so what I've said with Democrats is, you
know, the Republican Party voted en masse
against the one piece of legislation we were
able to put on the floor to lower inflation.
So you wedge that and you hit them over the
head with one theme.
They had a chance to act against inflation.
And what did they do?
They put politics over you.
Speaker 1: Is there any Senate race right
now that you consider to be any kind of bellwether
in a sense, or are the things that are happening,
for example, in the Walker Warnock race in
Georgia, completely unrelated to what's happening
with like Oz Fetterman in Pennsylvania or
like what are you what are you looking at
in terms of specific races?
Speaker 6: Well, I mean, we've got a really
interesting scenario when it look when we
think about Ares and Walker.
I mean, both of these are really tremendously
weak candidates.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I think part of Pennsylvania was
always going to be a toss up and maybe advantage
Fetterman against a normal nominee.
And then luckily, it's not as a product of
a bad nominee.
And also what the Fetterman campaign is doing
with the clay that they have.
Okay.
So getting a bad nominee is one thing.
Getting making use of that and using it as
an effective branding weapon against your
opponent is another.
Okay.
And so the reason we're seeing such good numbers
out of Georgia and Pennsylvania right now
is because both of those campaigns, when aggressive,
especially the outside groups, too, in the
case of Georgia, on branding the opponent
and creating a disqualified, you know, disqualification
effect.
And that's really what Democrats have to do
in a bit in this midterm.
So normally, you know, you might look at Republicans
and be like, okay, you know, inflation's high.
They're not offering you inflation solutions.
Right?
They run against one thing.
And that is Democrats are socialists that
want to turn your men child into women.
And we're going to save you from that.
Right.
So like when we think of that, so you think
about inflation and what that party is offering,
they are so weak on the economy that it should
not be hard at all for Democrats to disqualify
Jean.
And so when I talk about messaging on economy,
on a on democracy, rights, freedom and abortion,
which all tie in, I'm really talking about
messaging that is focused squarely on the
Republican Party, making sure people understand
what that party looks like today, how crazy
and dangerous it is for them personally.
Speaker 1: The asymmetrical aspect to this
between Republicans and Democrats seems almost
like scarily present in the Walker versus
Warnock race, because, I mean, Walker can
barely explain a single position like he can't
the guy can barely speak.
And we've talked before, like, is it CTE from
football?
Is it.
There's all these different things you can
speculate about.
He can't articulate his position on any issue,
and yet he's only losing by like eight or
nine points or something like that, which
just shows the completely different standards
that Republicans have for who they're willing
to vote for.
Speaker 6: Oh, exactly.
Yeah.
No, I mean, here's the thing.
Once you get late in partnership, it's not
like no one's paying attention to this stuff
right now that we know about.
So, you know, once once the campaign actually
gets going in September and the like, the
rest of the marginal voting population gets
brought into the conversation.
Actually, what you're going to see is a vote
share probably will go up, not down, dude.
And that's because a lot I mean, it is the
oh, they voted for a lobbyist child predator
in Alabama 9010 in that special election that
Doug Jones won and Doug Jones won it.
Okay.
But he did not win it because Republicans
rejected a child predator.
He won it because of a sort of massive turnout
and black vote and black voter turnout.
And, you know, a little bit of conversion
pull, pull off.
That was kind of like a perfect storm that
allowed him to do it.
But if they'll put him in the Senate, this
man that that had a New York, you know, 11
accusations of being a child predator or they'll
put everybody in there doesn't matter because
what their job, what they care about now is
seizing power and then using it to crush us.
Speaker 1: So let's talk a little bit in the
last few minutes, we have about the way in
which 20 to may impact 24 specifically for
Trump and Biden.
There is the idea that depending on how Trump
endorsed and MAGA people do in 2022, it will
impact whether Trump tries to be the nominee
in 24.
Another perspective is Trump's going to try
because he thinks it'll keep him out of legal
trouble.
So there's like the Trump side of things on
the Biden side.
I've never really felt Biden plan to run for
reelection in 24.
I just don't think he's doing it.
I don't think he ever really wanted to.
Jen Psaki, from the get go would say Joe Biden
intends to run.
And then when Kamala Harris said he's running
the next day, she walked it back and said
his intention is.
So I just I just don't think he's he's running
for reelection.
How does what happens in 22 impact the potential
candidacies of either of those two people?
Speaker 6: I mean, I've got to tell you, these
two elections roll together, guys.
If we do not show up in large numbers and
defend democracy here in 20 do, then we stand,
potentially lose, lose the governorships.
No matter how bad the candidates are in Michigan
and Pennsylvania, if we were to lose either
one of those, then we lose the blue wall,
the big three, and that's the big three.
That's 270.
So we can lose Georgia, we can lose Arizona,
and we may well lose those two fascist Republicans
if people vote.
But at the end of the day, like we cannot
lose Michigan and Pennsylvania are we do not
have a guarantee of a free and fair election
at all for 2024.
I mean, imagine a newly minted Republican
governor of Michigan.
Do you think they're going to be on the side
of democracy or outside fascism?
I'm going with fascist.
Speaker 1: What do you think about the Biden
24 thing?
Have you given any thought to it?
Speaker 6: You know, here's what I would say
is if he doesn't plan on running, he doesn't
act like that.
To me, he's as cautious and he traditional
first term president, which is, you know,
if I had to offer a criticism to the administration,
it would be that this is this is a moment
for Churchill, not Chamberlain.
We need Winston Churchill in in pastorally
in that leadership position.
We need somebody speak, very frankly, headed
into 22 about the stakes of this election,
what's on the ballot across these 50 states
and state legislatures and federal House elections?
Because, you know, at the end of the day,
he's got the bully pulpit and nobody else
has that bully pulpit.
And I honestly think whether his intends to
run or not, that would serve him best politically,
too.
Speaker 1: But right now, you don't question
that his plan is to run for reelection.
Speaker 6: I just don't bother speculating
about stuff like that right now, David.
I'm really focused on trying to keep democracy
from falling into a fascist pit.
Speaker 1: Fair.
That's a good that's a good thing to focus
on, I would say, actually.
We've been speaking speaking with Rachel Bitter
Copper Election Forecaster Analyst.
The podcast is The Election Whisperer.
Rachel, always a pleasure having you on.
Thank you.
Speaker 6: Yeah, thank you so much.
And if you don't mind to plug my new book,
please, it's going to be coming up 2023 by
Crown and it's called Hit Them Hit It Hurts
How to how to Save Democracy by beating Republicans
at their own game.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm sure we'll have you on
to talk about it when the book is out.
Yeah, for sure.
Thank you, Rachel.